bene tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
momento sono favi già oggi siamo dati su
make up pur con pietro purtroppo c'è
pietro però forse riusciamo a finirlo
anche se c'è pietro
buona visione ciao sono morte insomma è
uno slider non avevo capito e non si
capisce qua no no no no sono salvo e
sono anche lorenzo a volte oggi partiamo
male amico mio se partiamo male continui
male adesso rai lento devi riuscire la
smetti di fissarmi il personaggio della
cee volare 9 ho mai capito no allora da
qua in teoria dovresti saltare a questo
esattamente qui sopra e poi dallo stesso
ed al contrario lo slang ci porta sul
tetto ha visto era più visi di quanto
pensassi un uomo guarda che ti sei un
appetito mamma mia ti ammazzo ti odio ti
ammazzo ma non vale così vivo e non vale
non messi apposta e ma non credo che si
ma figurati l'hanno messa in tutti e
anche nei prima ho fatto così sicuro che
questi così non vadano aperti perché ne
hanno messi apposta suo nome a cubo
vabbè ma no
bene ci sono il canon scoperti con la
cover la cover per i grazie al gioco
esatto grazie ai creatori di questa
mappa che come ti chiami forse non lo sa
nessuno
così giovanni con lo so le gru e
knowledge gombar paio di io ce la sto
facendo io sono forte
oddio ma possiamo dire che sono invalido
in questo momento si può essere allora
pietro al dito fasciato oggi mi dice
busi problema è che a me non frega
niente gioca meglio col dito fascia di
qua e dico loro così li ho fatti
sì l'ho fatto già il lime ma come io
sono cortissimo decaduto amico sa che
sono veramente avanti di green credimi
sto facendo cose incredibili nostro
caduto
peggio è tutto dubbio una bandiera
altissimi non toccata volgerà a mare
aperto ma è una botola
efficacia per un attimo ho pensato ci
portasse un livello più indietro 6 siamo
al quarantesimo amico mio il
quarantesimo hoc che io arrivo alla fase
divertente tel mi sembra che cova da
[Applauso]
sono forte sì sì ma no dai variante vado
sono ancora è esattamente lo stesso in
cui sono morto io prima quel pezzo
veramente stronzo è veramente orribile
sono fatta puro ok già fatta si no va
benissimo
ce lo sto facendo ce l'ho fatta sempre
alla fine al pezzo dopo internato per
avercela fatta in teoria se non cado
adesso c'è pato mia ho tirato una
testata mi sono salvato uguale
incredibile non ci credo al rhein e fred
che ho fatto fatto amaca devi devi devi
proprio affogati a cui sistema più
veloce sott'acqua e non lo sapevo va beh
vedo le cose qua ma ho capito vai su 321
verso l'infinito e oltre ma è fighissimo
anzi tu metti un pistino slime sul
pistone salti a quanto quale si fingono
io speravo non lo sapevo m funzionali ma
non so saltare ti rendi conto che se
cadi di rifarti tutto vero tutto poi
d'acqua valiente qua poi d'acqua da
icona e poi d'acqua in casino
occhio che sbatti la capa
ok guarda signore ce l'ho fatta
sono forte occhio non è vero sono caduto
giù devo rifare tutto la mia vita fa
schifo sono forte esalta
vabbè facile lo fa restare così com'è è
bellissimo gioco è di quasi un passaggio
amico
no no no no no non ti guardo guardano
gamer che gli animali sono fatta e anche
perché non so dove andare di qua
ok ma non è difficilissimo dai a bergen
l'esperto pietro 321 sì bisogna
incontrare rovescia c'erano otto anni ho
dovuto fare da solo ho rotto anche nel
del fieno e l'ultimo passaggio
forse devi tenere shift cpt si tiene
d'allenarsi è che ne so io amico guarda
mi ci sarei ci vai ti prego non ci credo
dai vai vai avanti
more o paurissima dico ciao
eccolo salve è un giorno era maggio yo
allora se la poti faceva reparto da
madonna no perché livello nuovo no no no
no no no a proposito di atto adesso
serve pieni papa sa misurate ma sei un
pezzente simone radiare dal mondo si
svuota e colla a good ending
mamma mia sarà quanto il lungo arrivare
fino ai fondaco turia sì me ne sono
accorto perfetto ciao posizione inverse
di sopra di si passa voler tornare
indietro parti ammazzi nevicò vieni qui
ammazzi da solo non c'e neanche bisogno
che lo faccio io sono contento da esalta
no no no no no
stavo lottando salvata ce l'ho fatta
solo fortissimo ancora anche che il tuo
ostacolo cioè normative tese non sono
forte difficoltà quest'anno a io
guardavo lo slime non deriva da lo slime
mamma sei caschi ricorribile d occhio
davvero è magico di sé mamma mia che
kakà
mamma mia che kakà con quale coraggio ho
fatto questa parte
perfetto allora mio dio
che fastidio sto gioco andava avanti pio
e non so come ho fatto seguito
annunciato quasi a caso ho beccato il
punto giusto
ma ce lo slime ok ok no no no no no si
contento di dire tali parole ai via
perché i'm here due che sono lo sponsor
se lo sponsor aspetta che non so molto
bene molto bene porta player proprio lui
allora aspetto che aspetta bravo ma l'on
e invece no non è difficilissimo brava e
invece è difficile ecco ace l'ultimo
aspetta la più che non ci credo l'ultimo
livello
sì certo cosa mi fa di risalto alla
quale di avere in corso da parte simili
ce l'ho fatta ho fatto si è fatta largo
g
mi aspetta che devo fare un salto un po
strano tipo qua a destra
bravo guarda sei un pezzente ma non sono
caduto dopo che ti ho aspettato otto ore
tra l'altro prova venire qua adesso ci
prova l'ultimo assalto l'ultimo salto
jolo ce la fa con una ma sai scrivere
non lo faccio provaci tu ma io muoia
noci ma non so che cosa si provi per non
farlo renault parallelo fino in terza
persona tra l'altro sarà un po servirà
un po di tempo si ma la seconda
non è difficilissimo ho fatto la
soddisfazione di andare a finire un
livello prima si attiva a cadere sempre
coi muscoli allora montagna ok ok da
quale altra stagione dana ok glazed
light school di it's good day school
demo ok sorry quindi mettiamo che le
recinzioni hanno due blocchi jeans
allora aspetta di qua ma qua devi cadere
decina porta a perché da di noè vino
cibo
buongiorno di quello molino perché lì
non ci poteva perché lì non ci poteva
arrivare da solo porco schifo non avevo
capito
ok ok c'è un problema cioè io non faccio
che è i very good e ma ora secondo i nas
cosino minacci 6.000 volete è salire
sopra ma va o figlia di avere ragione
e poi lo sbaglio ma allora aspetti che è
un casino ma quindi serviva sociali ma
qualcosa no della serie se cadi ti rifai
tutto comunque ma che la bellissima tra
ce l'ho fatta lo hai fatto
no no a grandissimo è una trappola dai
mi è crollato il pavimento questa parte
un casino fiat sta ripetendo no ma ce
l'ho fatta prima di voglia di fare e poi
acqua o finito è quello era praticamente
hai visto era boboli a aver vinto in
modo da fini praticavano molte le nomine
quando di fatto tutto rischiano la voce
l'acqua qua a ganna guarda no volevo
fare volevo tirati la botta pratica
dezza era cattivo come lo sarà per la
ok ci sono questa rosa e mangiato
problema per qualche tipo di nasconderlo
così questa e renderlo diversamente
colorato tele fatta e come hai fatto
male difficile e quello dopo è difficile
ok
mamma mia è giocata cosa facciamo schifo
brava però qua è bravo poi di qua penso
di bravo bravo amico nuovo amico così
giusto io non brava mesolino per gravami
con il calendario bravo amico mamma mia
cosa sto facendo
facendo cose fortissimo e adesso io ce
l'ho fatta ho fatta portale ed è mica
perfetto mammamia avventa credo che le
ninfe che volino c'entrino qualcosa
salento
penso di sì è vero da qua proprio
partito al lago allora allora allora
allora perché devi andare solo potrei
che è vero no ti prego ti prego ci pensi
seccati dico ed è ripartita la mia se ti
riesce bene doppia le scimmie hai visto
che bravo e facevo le scimmie pietre
delle scimmie si vede porca vacca è
accaduto ok alto sinistra perché è così
bravi grazie amico che mi hai dato una
mano se non c'ero io va bene adesso dove
andiamo
ora arriva la parte più difficile ecco
qua ti devi aggrappare a brown eyes e
amico migrans penati francoforte niente
io non vado loschi fontana ma posso
saltata acqua che più in alto infatti
interno interno bene
scusi compriamo quello che ci basta e
non era acqua quella comunque no no
madonna stavo cadendo linea uomo che ho
capito ho capito è uno slam quindi
giampà dinamica fa abbiamo fatto
vabbè scusa amianto dico più niente ho
preso acqua
ok siamo 18 adesso e moto di sale e va
bene come di bye bye giù per torna su ok
quali i falchi ponticello molto bene
molto bene e adesso lo sly per arrivare
da quella parte lì e secondo me non si
può fare ok devi fare il giro ti fa ci
fregano visto gioco porca vacca potevi
incentrare esattamente quel coso capito
eh ma ora è tutta una scoperta e mo ma
dopo come ci arrivo di sopra e devi fare
il giro della colonna porca vacca morta
persone fra quattro my friends
ho fatto un buon cross the world 66
papalino forse ci hai rinunciato leger
adesso dobbiamo fare un altro giro molto
divertente su due strade l'oro ha due
strade vero io vado a destra la sinistra
non è vero adesso non ci può andare è
chiusa la botola
come no penso sia un check point ap ai
talmente veramente difficile che c'è un
check point stava dicendo quello e poi
sa dovrebbe essere rincorriamo cia c'è
poi ad arquà fin qua ok
fin qua ok io a volte vorrei anch'io
omicidi sì me ne rendo conto
scusami ce l'ho fatta sono bravo sulla
liana mamma mi aspettavo fosse scala
parti c'è poi un what ho capito cosa
devo fare e difficile
mamma mia vieni vieni non cadere non
cadere su twitter al bravissimo ora di
fare una cosa che io l'app la feci io la
feci prova ci sei molto più bravo di
quanto pensassi ecco c'è poi si sa cosa
mi vorrei aprire la botta di sei mesi e
mezzo per un pulsantino cercare bene e
abbia finito lì nella a era un bel però
era un patè vader come come è sotto le
cose non lo so guarda non ci credo vabbè
ok online dopo ok
sorry i'm born slippy di mont a 50 siamo
a metà i ragazzi viene vissuto con sento
lasciato un bel commento è un mi piace
sta cosa hanno fatto a caso anche per i
soci che colmi di via tutto nella
schizzare se non saperci rischiate era
come sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
visto da ragazzi
[Musica]